all right hello everyone how is Jim hope
you guys are having a wonderful day
today we're here with another video in
the base video will be a low-level money
making guide that can make you a little
bit over 500 50k per hour so this is
going to be a method that actually does
really help low levels as you will be
able to get about 50k crafting XP per
hour and 35k magic XP on top of the 550
K cash you'll be making per hour now as
far as the requirements you will need 45
crafting to be able to craft the amulets
that will be crafting today and in
addition to that you will need 49 magic
to be able to charge them now those are
the only two requirements for this
particular method however there are a
lot of variations that you can have
different levels for if you wish to try
those yourself with that said the method
that we will be using today will be a
method of making topaz amulets and then
enchanting them whenever you do this you
actually do make a burny amulet 3 and
burning amulets actually have a really
good price point on them right now so if
we go ahead and look at the prices that
I paid for mine personally it comes in
at about 2100 per one and I mean it's
not it's not too bad as you can see you
can buy them in bulk for the most part
there is one thing that I would
recommend though and that's a slow buy
the red topaz they really buy pretty
quickly it didn't take me long at all to
buy 2000 and instant buy them sometimes
I have really crazy margins so you may
actually be paying 200 or 300 more coins
and you actually need to per one and
that could hurt how much you make off of
each one of these now as far as what you
will be doing basically you want to go
to some sort of furnace that you can use
personally I'm going to be using the one
in the e Edgeville area and what you're
gonna want to do is throw everything
into your bank once you have it all in
here go ahead and grab out your amulet
mold you're going to want to grab 13
silver bars and thirteen topaz run over
to a smithing furnace it can be this one
or any one obviously and once you use
the silver bar on it you'll get an
option to craft hope as amulets unstrung
go ahead and do that the inventories are
pretty quick and this is where you get a
decent amount of crafting experience you
actually get eighty per one and you can
do a decent amount of amulets per hour
it comes out to about 600 in total but
you can do this in different ways if you
want if you only have say maybe three to
four hundred you'll be making those full
amulets in an hour
but say if you have a thousand like I do
I'll personally be spending about 40
minutes doing this instead and not
making all the amulets in one hour or
take me more time than that now what
you're gonna want to do either you can
continue to make all of the amulets
unstrung until you have finished or just
for this example I will
now go ahead and show you what you would
want to do if you have these amulets so
what you're gonna want to do if you have
the ambulance unstrung go ahead and find
your balls of wool grab out 14
personally I only have 13 my inventory
right now and then go to make off once
you do that you'll be stringing the
amulets into topaz amulets essentially
almost completing the process all you
have to do from here is be able to cast
the level-3 enchantment and that will
charge and actually make these amulets
useful one thing really weird though
that is actually kind of helpful is the
fact that these amulets looks so much
different than when they are charged now
let me go ahead and grab some cosmic
runes you can fill up a whole inventory
of this however this is kind of the one
part that does actually require some
click intensive type work as you can see
I click that and you can see a really
big difference between the two it's nice
because something like emerald rings you
don't see a difference and so you can
kind of forget which ones you charge or
not the OS buddy client also helps with
that if you are doing something other
than these no what you're gonna want to
do is just go ahead and enchant all the
amulets and you'll be making about eight
to nine hundred GP per one whenever you
do this personally I was paying twenty
one hundred for all of the supplies
needed for each amulet basically this is
going to be what you would require every
amulet that you make will have the input
of these four items for me it came out
to around twenty one hundred coins and
that's how much I paid for them however
for you it could be higher or lower
depending on the time that you're doing
it now with that said I'm gonna go ahead
and do a thousand of these burning
amulets and come back to you when I am
done one thing I'd like to add is the
fact that because I'm releasing this
video there may be less of a margin on
these amulets in particular however
there are a ton of new well not
necessarily new but somewhat new amulets
and just other jewelry within the game
so you don't necessarily need to follow
this exact formula that I'm showing you
feel free to take a look at any of these
other types of amulets or any rings or
anything that's coming from these new
updates there's really good margins and
a lot of these so make sure to check
those before you go ahead and do this
one in particular alright and here we
are a little while later so I did end up
selling all of the amulets which is
really nice disregard the dragon darts
but all of the amulets did sell for
twenty nine hundred and sixty eight GP
pretty much given me a profit of eight
hundred and sixty to eight hundred
seventy per one really nice stuff and I
mean it is a really good money making
method for low levels as you can make a
decent amount of cash per hour lingering
between five to six hundred K and you
get a lot of XP and crafting and
magic both levels that you will need to
get up whenever you're a mid-level
account or even a low-level account at
that so hopefully you guys enjoyed the
video hopefully you guys found it
helpful if you guys did make sure to
leave a like if there's anything you
want to tell me go ahead and comment
that down below if you guys enjoy my
content make sure you subscribe to the
channel and if you want to help me out
and any other form of the way just feel
free to stop on by and say hi whether
that be on my Twitter also in the
description this court also in the
description and you know largely XP lamp
the clan chat but with that said
hopefully you guys have a wonderful day
and
you